how did they do that you see that's all
off see the shadow should be completely
different that the poor should move this
is usually something about their videos
start we're gonna watch more core
recruited a VFX artist react to battle
grade CGI number 21 let's check it out
[Music]
top three coolest action on this at all
time what is movie all the background
you're seeing is not real hey what's up
welcome back to another episode of the
digital effects artist react we got Sam
on the couch today instead of Clinton
rip Clint but you know I got the funnies
and I got those natty reactions I have
no idea what we're gonna be taking a
look at today except for one thing that
I'm super excited about which is the
mandalorian yes [ __ ] that way
we're starting with the good damn what
is this it is a feast for the eyes what
in them tell me zero yachts is basically
just one long fight scene damn is crazy
looking for one long cool fight scene of
monsters it's all costume change looks
like already player what just basically
takes all the coolest guns
smart and lasers Akira lasers mostly
lasers from pop culture and combined
with a cool monster fight scenario damn
I need to see this dude he just went to
tell this guy didn't shop and then
regrowing it's such a cool effect and
it's not that easy to do with
complicated models at this so this guy
gets chopped by swords they're basically
ruining you know the different parts of
him and then like changing those Marines
to read the row stuff it's like a 3d
printer ya have to use like a 3d printer
this scene oh my god this is the top
three coolest action moments of all time
with the creativity in the weaponry and
this wow it is so insane just wait was
it gonna slice through them like a
lightsaber better Lopez that may upload
where
to outer space it's a teleportation gun
the monster away from the so cool like I
love that they have to cover like a
texture map that's basically just like a
cat scanned like brain yeah and that's
like just probably an animated texture
map it's playing on like a plane as they
like you know for sure
wait so that's 3d printing gun yeah
somewhere in space good sandwich very
fine deli meats
Jared transition so he's teleporting
right once life that time it's the
first-person view what happens when your
eyes get teleported what the hell is
this movie want some pairing stuff going
on here how is he able to think when his
brains in another location oh yeah
basically just one giant like real for
the effects company there it is yes okay
don't show any more I gotta watch this
tonight great green screen Wow well the
whole thing's great screen here's the
thing for how bad but yet good the room
is this green screen is really well done
I mean clips of these scenes it goes
something's up with it but I instantly
forgot about it and stopped it like
analyzing it like it was so you have to
do huh TIFF to where I was just like oh
maybe the Lighting's just a little
weirder the cameras we have oh I wasn't
like oh he's pretty solid green screen
did the perfect mirror symmetry that
building behind them they're kind of
like rotated their 360 degrees just a
little oh my god you're right for me the
brakes I almost on this is just the
lighting and the edge feather oh yeah
especially that Shari is coming out of
the
doorway they're like yeah where does
that door lead manhole what they're
doing is it looks like a giant panorama
that's just at a very far away distance
so there's no parallax from like that
house just behind the building and like
the building's off in the distance it's
just an image but it is tracked in 3d
space just all at the same distance
behind the wall it's great but like it's
directed in a way like so it's such a
clear vision it's a good indication like
if you have really clear a director of
Asian you're gonna make something unique
yes these sets are insane what do you
think they found this warehouse room to
a filmic dusting by the previous Star
Wars movies they probably made a giant
green-screen stage and then filmed
everything with the actors having no
idea what it were or what a context of
what they're doing but this is a TV show
they don't have time to do all the
effects for a place where we every
single shot I don't have time for that
okay what we're getting at in this scene
all of the background you're seeing is
not real it is nice real-time rendered
image on a LED screen my screen and it
is not a real set either there's a card
ejection I've got a real pretty much
everything in the foreground that the
actors are interacting with is real okay
you know if you just go ten feet beyond
that suddenly it becomes a fake set
people have done this in the past before
yeah the thing that makes this
revolutionary is that they're able to
utilize it with a moving camera mm-hmm
the camera they are oh my god
Reidy tracked and the screen is
constantly adjusting the perspective of
the background to match the camera oh
how cool raizy and the only way you can
do that is by using a real-time game
engine this is not done after the fact
this is done at frame by frame so
everything the camera is capturing goes
through the lens and that's why it looks
so natural the greatest thing about
go back to the cinema characters
actually line up their shot it's a very
seamless very streamlined process and it
allowed this whole production to get all
these crazy what amazing technology yeah
yeah it's crazy how you can do interior
and exterior scenes with it at all times
there's a guy with unreal loaded up on a
workstation and if they are trying to
get a certain shot they literally can
just move all the assets flawless
composition so we were actually
fortunate enough to experience this
technology in person unreal
divided us out to one of their
demonstrations with one of their like
stages now on this stage they actually
had a scene set up you can see them
really clearly how the ambient light of
this real-time environments being
rendered in the wheel is actually
affecting the lighting on us in the
foreground how a mess Hey look good
because there's no like king that needs
to be pull like our hair actually looks
correct the light blues directly around
us and most importantly when you're
there acting you can just look around
and see the environment you don't have
to pretend yeah what's really cool about
the stages it also solves a lot of the
common issues you face when filming on a
green screen such as very reflective and
glass transparent objects that you can
still properly see through trying to
pull a key on some of this stuff is
basically impossible and this fixes all
that it's so inspiring that look
literally right now I'm working on a
mini version of this that was in our own
led walls but it's gonna have the
capability to 3d track a camera you know
as we're filming it in real time we are
making a video about all of that and if
you want to see it
subscribe
here we go this is what we all came here
for this is a creature and they can't
afford to have you know eight episodes
of a CG creature like this in every
scene
so they have an amazing actual physical
puppet well shucks like this where he's
walking down the ramp
that's a CG baby Yoda and what's
interesting is that they actually
fine-tuned and revised the animation of
the CG kind of puppet life and make it
seem like the real puppet the entire
time that's a really common issue you
face with visual effects is very often
in reality it's not we've been trained
to see in movies no squibs yeah and
people get shot movies that's not what
real bullet hits look like there's
reality and then there's Hollywood
reality and everyone thinks that totally
good reality is what things actually
look like so if you make it look like
real they think it looks fake obviously
that's not a living creature even with
the most flawless rendering and movement
and animation are you you never get to
convince someone that it's real but if
you can convince them it's a moment well
puppets are real so now it's really like
your scene let me see like baby Oda
actually walking it's a CG baby of them
so they're currently filming season two
of the mandalorian right now and there's
so much that they learned on making this
one that they're basically designing
sets around this concept and I love that
idea so much oh I can't wait for season
oh look a bit better
we need to finish this show bathtub
scene is man I haven't actually seen The
Witcher on Netflix just yet so I'm
getting a little preview the hexer what
is the hex room you were saying we
should watch the dragon part rend and oh
yeah it is the casting henry cavill has
made a complete transformation okay so
it's a polish witcher movie that came
out in 2001 yes the original wicker I
don't know why you like the show so much
ran into socks oh my god ooh we're
disturbing in some ways cloud they
probably just had no money to throw on
visual effects let alone anything but
should we do the dragon we there's no
way we can do it well and they're like
sure
[Music]
yeah Wisconsin it was come no that's
really not imagine a door explodes brief
guide the horses plan of the plains like
yeah that makes sense TV show movie
scene a good bad V effect doesn't matter
she's doing the comical actually I have
a special request I want to do a
reaction to game cinematics so you guys
have a game Oh Batman Arkham origins way
to show you every fatality
[Music]
well very used to seeing dragons and
shows and movies and so jerks
specifically the gold dragon suffers a
little bit this shot stands out to me as
being a little rough and it's a TV show
I get those CG dragon feet are touching
that wall and you can see like between
its toes the wall is still bright and
it's a little string like lookup dark
the Dragons feet are the Dragons they're
dark because there's no light hitting
them especially since it's like you have
this huge dragon yeah roots no didn't
notice it right away should be pretty
dark in general underneath him
the lights coming from that one hole in
the K and that's basically acting is a
giant softbox yet the dragon shadows
here are crisp on the wall it's a little
strange having crisp shadow from a box
Neverland I like the cause of the shot
here in what makes it seem weird is the
fact that they're blending a live-action
plate that's in a challenging lighting
scenario with the CG dragon whereas I
feel like if you were to re-approach
this shot you'd probably be better to
make the entire environment 100% CG what
do you have a 3d model the dragon and
you're trying to have me go through a
live plate what you're doing is you're
guessing the three-dimensional geometry
of that space if you don't get it like
spot on it can start looking a little
bit weird where the scene feels flat or
flatter than it should be and I think we
see that with the feet here I feel like
they blew their entire VFX budget on the
opening scene of the first episode yeah
nice place
it's like chopping a crab leg man it's
great this was a great opening the show
and I saw this I was like oh man this is
gonna be great
[Applause]
and then his face there and you know I
just kind of like that's great go that's
some good V effects yeah that's like in
the moment and gone man you freaking
pulled that finger on me by throwing the
original Witcher so I'll never forgive
me for that
hey guys we have a special message for
you yeah that's right bleep here is
today when this video comes out and we
want to do something super special so we
went back in time then we grabbed was
the most demanded one of the coolest
items ever the anime self-driving car
long sleeve that's right it's also gonna
be paired up with a one-time-only retro
dashboard magnet so you guys are this
refactor this weekend only the animate
self-driving car long sleeve and the DEF
misjudgment is gonna be available only
then there's a bunch of other stuff on
the store we got that packed
we got hats joggers celery yes that
one's celery now course eligible so
we've got the animated self-driving car
long sleeve back from the vault as well
as a bunch of other really cool awesome
we dig sweet I'm really excited for the
game cinematic one that one's gonna be
awesome if anything what they should be
covering a lot will be like cinematic
trailers because sometimes those scenes
that the trailers aren't in the actual
video games they'll have plenty of
grateful I'm sure they got like one too
many recommendations to go off of but
I'm definitely gonna be keeping a
lookout for that one introduced this is
a pretty cool stuff the hexler god watch
that as soon as possible I gotta check
out the hexer dragon man that blows
dragon heart out of the water in some
ways that dragon was more disturbing
than the one that yay get in The Witcher
Netflix series kind of looked like if a
lawnmower man was a dragon hello I
closed up which I was just watching I
think a caravan of garbage where
did the Godzilla 99 and that has an eye
close-up that's not great and this one
is even more not greater than that the
gods zero footage just looked incredible
we got to watch that right away I don't
even really know what they fully
discussed here about that yeah you're
just introducing us to how awesome is
Ruby it's I was just like yeah you're
just kind of illustrating that this
looks insane and has like cool
theoretical technology in it that's
certainly just an amazing looking demo I
love when Studios do stuff like that
where they're like this is awesome also
this is just one gigantic business card
exactly it kind of reminded me of like a
kung fury type thing something that
looks like it's gonna be just a fever
dream yeah of crazy set pieces one thing
I really loved about what they talked
about here was the real-life reality
versus movie reality kulluk Instagram
models you know the girls really look
like that in real life and do they say
as many inspiring things on the regular
know that is social media reality no
sorry but in real reality they're all
ugly and disgusting and obese as f
they're the trolls who are giving you
hate comments yeah so there's real life
it's kind of like what I've heard about
him doing impressions when you do an
impression of someone you want to
actually go a little bit over the top
with it because if you go for a hundred
percent accuracy people might not
actually pick up on it it's kind of a
strange thing for the year and I didn't
actually associate that with movies that
if you go for a hundred percent reality
like what they're talking about with the
squibs cuz I've never seen someone get
shot in real life those are kind of like
a punch you know like oh yeah what else
just don't sound like yeah when someone
gets punched in real life that that
sound really hurts like if you hear a
real-life like bang bang against the
skull
yeah knuckle hitting it's a really
painful sound but in a movie it just
doesn't translate like there's something
that seems off if there isn't a sound
effect punch sound effect what they did
with the covering the mandalorian I had
heard about that but I hadn't seen any
footage and that's kind of like what
Nolan did for interstellar actually
where to be in the space secret citizen
for the actress to feel like it's really
real they built these like digital sound
stages so that way they could really
feel like they were in outer space to
know that they did that with them
andalorian especially after what they
did with the prequels for Star Wars
I really just admire the hell out of
that because one thing I'm always giving
actors credit for in these big CGI
blockbuster films how much imagination
these actors have to pull even if they
have great directors are able to tell
them what's there and what's not there
at the end of the day they're still
working solely off of their imagination
so with the cinematographers the VFX
artists working hand-in-hand like
getting real in time game engineers yeah
you something use your imagination at
the same time though it makes it easier
to hone in on your imagination when you
can get lost
in the images around you I thought that
was so beautiful and the fact that are
even updating it and working around it
for the season - I can only imagine how
much better it's gonna look because
there are scenes in the mandalorian that
they were showing us I had no idea those
backgrounds are CGI it's like yeah some
of it is real but for the most part
they're still working primarily with CGI
even with that screen it's still CGI or
even if it's a real picture yeah is not
actually there and they're so convincing
it looks like they went to locations and
shot that's the most exciting thing from
this video to me is I remember when
oblivion dropped and I saw kind of
behind the scenes thing where they
showed this technology and yeah the
digital matte painting the digital
environments I remember when drones
first came on the scene like the amount
of time and equipment you can save there
just seems exponential and it's the same
here I can only imagine it's like they
said they're about to get that kind of
setup in their studio so I can only
imagine what kind of breakthroughs are
gonna make that even easier to access
and then you can have an even wider
breadth of possibilities which are
movies and then yeah with the allottee
you know that bridges so many gaps cuz
not only is it great for the actors but
it's also yeah perfect for the lighting
the motion of the camera and in terms of
that reality versus movie reality that
is a great point and it's something I
think they've touched on before because
they've done it with sound and the way
like when people fire guns the order you
usually hear the pop and the you know
impact in is not the same and like with
Gore a lot of the time like a bit and
the Museum of Death they have a lot of
pictures of actual gore and it doesn't
look quite like movie Gore and there's
like a way in which real gore kind of
doesn't look quite real partly because
we're conditioning my movies I find that
stuff fascinating but I think that's why
violence in movies like Tarantino
what he does with like the squibs and
stuff I think that's why back can be fun
there's always that age-old argument of
life this is promoting violence and
stuff but when you see like movie
violence versus real life violence it's
two completely different things yeah one
is greatly unsettling and very
disturbing and then there's a reason one
version of like a whole bunch of blood
splatter can be fun
and that's because it's it's whimsical
it's not really you know
all right Korra crew thanks for playin
together we're gonna be keeping a
lookout for your games reaction one
that's gonna be awesome subscribe to
corridor crew if you haven't done so
already make sure to subscribe to the
real rejects click our notification
bellow get notified never got a youtube
video up last but not least let's end
this with e mat beer it was also your
birthday recently since I come up with
most of the shoutouts just gonna shout
you out right now sing him happy
birthday John mad beer the regular
birthday song costs money so I'm gonna
sing you happy birthday myself but in a
slightly different melody mad beer I
love you and many more times we will
make out that last part I wasn't
supposed to tell people about but you
know it's time that we live free or die
hard